foreign
starts this hour in Chicago hi Caesar
how are you
I'm doing great you know what that's
Cesar is it Cesar or Caesar
it is like Julius Caesar got it okay I
did not mess it up good how can I help
thank you so much uh yeah I'm 26 years
old tuned in from Chicago I have
approximately a hundred thousands in my
savings I have approximately 50 000 in
mutual funds that it's parked in a Roth
IRA Roth 401k
and I feel like I have a lot of options
there's a lot of pressure to buy I think
I'm thinking about buying the building
and uh it's putting a lot of pressure on
me but it's a lot of options I really
don't know what to do at the moment and
I would like your advice about my
situation
do you have any debt
zero debt zero debt way to go are you
married
I am not married why isn't some woman
snapped you up that's right
no there's a woman trust me
yeah man you're killing it good you're
killing it way to go I'm proud of you
so is your person is your personal
residence paid off as well
or are you a buyer yet
I am renting at the moment in Chicago
and this is my situation for renting
it's a two-bedroom it's a thousand
dollars a month and I'm splitting it
with a roommate 500 each wow stole that
so you're not in a hurry to get out of
that no that's a deal I know so what
what they're not shooting down the
street are they
no no they're not actually they're not
sitting down the street
so what exactly is your question like
what are you hoping to get from this
call
okay there's a general question and
specific question I'm feeling a lot of
pressure to buy my own building a
multi-family unit home and to move into
those who is pressuring you um
you know that's a great question
it is
in Chicago it's like the thing to do you
know like
but that doesn't mean that's smart
um you know so I mean dude you you have
really good instincts you have really
good skills you are so far ahead of
normal normal sucks is broke has no
money I mean you got some money piled up
you've done a great job way to go uh if
you want to buy a condo to live in
that's fine but don't buy it because the
society the stupid thinks you should
right
okay you buy it because you got by
because you looked at it and you said I
like these numbers I mean you're the guy
living in a 500 rental situation in
Chicago
you're that guy right score you're the
smartest I know right you're the smart
guy be listening to him he's got more
going on so if you want to go buy you a
condo that's great you got a hundred
thousand dollars to put down and or you
need to set back an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
um and set back anything else you need
to purchase if you're thinking about
buying a car you're thinking about
buying whatever so that you don't go
into debt for the future items but after
that the rest of that money is your down
payment on a condo or whatever if you
want to buy something but
but when you say buy a building you know
what I'm hearing you've been reading
real estate investment crap on Tic Tac
that's what it sounds like
uh it's that my grandfather owns the
multi-family at home a lot of people in
my circle you know a lot of a lot of
them uh the older generation owns a
multi-family unit home so I was thinking
why don't I house hack get a register on
the top floor live on the first floor
and rent out the basement that's not a
bad idea but you should do it because as
you looked at it you thought a that's
how I want to live
because the great news is your tenants
are attached to you the bad news is your
tenants are attached to you
exactly they're going to be knocking on
the door at 2 A.M if they don't like
something unless you really set some
real clear boundaries it's very
difficult to manage a multi-family that
you live in from a boundaries
perspective so if you want to do that
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
that but there's nothing that says if
you don't do that that you're stupid
because you ain't stupid dude I know
that's right people need to be listening
to you instead of you listening to what
they're saying so if you want to take
but if you want to take them you want to
take 75 000 bucks what do you what do
you make
so I make approximately 75 000 a year
through my my full-time job and I also
own a business and what does it make
uh I'm combining the income from both oh
so you make 75 including owning a
business not awesome
so if you want to take 7500 leave 25 for
an emergency fund and you know you
continue out of your monthly budget
doing investing into your retirement
plan at your workplace then uh and you
want to go buy your multi-family and
live on the main floor there's nothing
wrong with that it's not a bad plan at
all but this idea that somehow
you know I I don't I here's here's a
good rule of thumb okay whatever
everyone else in America is doing do the
opposite and you'll probably have some
money true that now can I play devil's
advocate here why because I'm sitting
here thinking well here's my thought I'm
like okay if he was buying a personal
residence and he knows that he can
afford it without a rent without any
rentals you know just on his own great
but if he's buying this building that's
more expensive and he's depending on the
rent coming in should he not pay cash
for this property no no it wouldn't
matter if it's your residence and you're
going to take out a mortgage as long as
you can pay the payments and if you have
to have the rent to pay the payments no
that's what I want that's what my thing
with Caesar I want to make sure he
doesn't need the rent from the other
people living upstairs or downstairs you
don't go buy something that you can't if
your renters all don't pay you can't be
up a creek right so he's gotta you got
to be able to afford this regardless if
you have renters Caesar that's just a
little yeah
that'll keep because here's when you
have an empty apartment and you have to
make payments you become desperate and
when you become desperate right after
that that you get stupid and that's when
you put the wrong tenant in and you
create a bigger mesh than an empty
apartment creates that's true and so if
you don't have to make the payments if
you don't have to have somebody to stay
alive right you know inside the inside
the unit there then you make better
decisions on who goes in to the unit
well he's got his family but I'm also
thinking your family is also the ones
that is like hey this month's a little
tight
give me till next month so there's just
a little there's a little stuff there
that he he might need to consider before
going in absolutely absolutely but
overall do it because it's the lifestyle
you want to live I want to live on the
first floor I'm willing to do that at
this phase of my life I'm willing to
deal with tenants next door I'm not
doing this because my grandpa did it
right yeah I'm not doing this because I
saw it on Tic Tac that's we're not doing
that and um
you know until we arrived on the Tic Tac
scene about a month ago you could pretty
well say that whatever was said on there
was useless garbage we're trying to
displace it with some wisdom so I've had
a few things posted on there that did 10
20 million views and that kind of stuff
thank you guys I guess
um I think I should thank you yes thank
the people because they're making the
they're making the views go yeah well I
mean we got to put something good on
there to try to redeem the platform but
yeah but it's it's more full of get rich
quick crap than anything I've seen since
midnight cable